Speaker 1: I'm genuinely glad to see that more
people are sounding the alarm about the danger
that Ron DeSantis or as some know him wrong
DeSantis poses to American democracy. You know,
I've been talking about this for a long
time, and former guest on this program,
expert on fascism, Ruth Ben-ghiat, in
response to Jeb Bush endorsing Ron DeSantis,
despite DeSantis not even being a candidate at the
time, Ruth Ben-ghiat tweeted, quote, Ron DeSantis
will destroy our democracy with deadly precision.
I cannot emphasize enough how dangerous he is. So
Ruth clearly comes down on the side of what I've
been saying for a year now. DeSantis is bad, but
the real danger is that he's less incompetent than
Trump, and thus is far more likely if he becomes
president to successfully implement a lot of these
horrible and disastrous ideas. And increasingly,
the proof is in looking at what he has done in
Florida for the last couple of years. Now, in a
later segment, we're going to deal with this in a
sort of different way. But sort of as a reminder,
what exactly is it that DeSantis has succeeded
at doing in Florida? The don't say gay bill,
the entire Anti-woke feud with Disney disturbingly
authoritarian business freedom. Except when we
don't like what the business is doing, when
we don't like the opinion of your business.
The plan to overhaul the Board of trustees at the
historically liberal new College of Florida with
six new hand-picked conservative members chilling
when it comes to what supposed small government
conservatives want to do in putting their hands
right into the specifics of what higher learning
institutions, higher education institutions
are doing, trying to manipulate and control
what is in that advanced placement Black history
course that became the subject of much controversy
a few weeks ago. But the core of all of this is
that Trump and DeSantis are both sort of wannabe
authoritarians. Trump gets easily distracted
and is very incompetent. So through a sort of
like adult ADHD where he ends up just watching the
TV in the back of the room and his incompetence,
he doesn't end up getting that much done. And
so many of Donald Trump's failings in a sense,
were from just kind of not paying attention. Ron
DeSantis, on the other hand, is far less likely
to be ineffective for those reasons. The January
6th insurrection, had it been run by DeSantis,
would have had a greater chance of
succeeding. Not a guarantee it would
have succeeded. Probably still would not have,
but it certainly would have had more of a shot.
Trump also does a lot of things because he
wants his base to like him, and his interest
trumps interest in a lot of the things he thinks
of doing is geared around. I think my base will
like this and I think people will praise me
for it. DeSantis genuinely seems to have like
a culture war delusion that he has to win. And
as we've talked about, being a true believer in
a sense makes you more dangerous. Now, I want to
then add another caveat, because this DeSantis is
a complicated guy. DeSantis is not a dumb guy in
the way that Trump is kind of dim. And part of me
wonders whether DeSantis really believes any of
it personally. But as long as he's committed to
it because it's what he believes he has to do
for political expediency and to succeed, he is
still a true believer that it's what he should do,
even if personally he thinks a lot of these things
are kind of dumb ideas. So the big hope against
DeSantis and the dangers that he poses. Basically
comes down to his complete and total lack of
charisma. And we're going to look at some examples
of that in a moment. His complete and utter lack
of charisma might make him ill suited to actually
defeat Donald Trump in the national campaign
that we seem to be barreling towards, even though
DeSantis hasn't officially announced anything yet.
It is genuinely tough to find a less charismatic
person than Ron DeSantis, at least among the
people in the major spotlight right now. So
that's Ruth Ben-ghiat accurately concerned about
the threat that de Santos poses to democracy.
Let's now see what Ron DeSantis has been up to
in this growing civil war against Donald Trump.